Oppenheimer is told through two distinct
timelines one focused on oppenheimer's
Rise and another looking at Louis
strauss's attempts to tear his rival
down to distinguish the two Nolan
depicts oppenheimer's view in color
while strauss's is in black and white
this could be to make it clearer to
audiences that these storylines aren't
happening at the same time but it feels
like Nolan is attempting to do something
more with this what he's trying to
accomplish is so unclear though that
Nolan had to explain it before the film
even released saying one is in color and
that's oppenheimer's subjective
experience then the other is a black and
white timeline it's a more objective
view of his story from a different
character's point of view while this
explanation does clear up what Nolan was
going for that concept of subjective
versus objective doesn't necessarily
come through in the film ultimately the
choice makes things a little murky both
thematically and in terms of
Storytelling